- Welcome back y'all,
our next guest has been nominated
for Grammy Awards in both
country and rock genres
cause she's that cool.
Her latest album is called,
"Come Get Your Wife". (laughs)
I love it.
It's available now wherever
you get your music.
Everybody please welcome Elle King!
(audience applauds)
(soft jazz music)
- Okay, so,
you, you love like a lot of
different genres of music
which is why I love you.
- Cool.
- So you, rock and country
you've been nominated for,
but what are like some
of your other influences?
You seem like you like blues a lot too.
- I love blues.
I love Southern rock and roll.
I love disco.
- Yeah.
- Disco's,
- Me too, I like to dance.
- Yeah, I like to dance too.
- Yes.
- I love emotional music
to like a driving beat.
So, that's why disco is like,
been kind of an inspiration in any genre
that I've ever played.
- Yeah.
- So, I don't know, I just,
I always go back to disco.
- Yeah. It makes you feel good.
- Yeah. Never lets you down.
- Absolutely.
Wha, congrats on becoming a mama as well.
- Thank you.
- That's exciting.
(audience coos)
- My gosh,
I will eat those cheeks.
- I know!
- Oh my gosh.
- He's so cute.
- He is so cute,
in that jacket coming off the shoul,
looks like an ad. (laughs)
(Elle laughs)
So how's your son doing?
- He's good.
He's a really incredible traveler.
He's so social and friendly
and warm and loves to share.
He's a little bit of an aggressive hugger,
but we're working on it.
- Yeah.
- I think that's, you
know, a quality problem.
But, he's so sweet and he
goes everywhere with me, so.
- I love that.
- Yeah.
- So when you say like,
he had a wild life,
my kids grew up too.
They're good travelers
because they kind of had to be
right off the bat.
- Yeah.
- But you grew up like that as well.
Obviously, your dad,
like, was it hard growing with a comedian
and him always being on the road?
Or did you get used to it?
- Comedians are not funny.
They have, I think they're,
a lot of comedians are
extremely intelligent
and they, they have this weird vision
and they use all of their joy
to make other people laugh
and then offstage.
But I also grew up around
a lot of my dad's friends
and they always were really,
really funny to be around.
But yeah, I don't know.
- I mentioned though that
you've been nominated
for Grammys in rock and country,
so this new album,
(audience applauds)
it's incredible.
I'm gonna keep saying it
cause it's an incredible
ta, feat,
but I, this one leans more country?
Is that what I'm hearing?
- Yes, definitely.
- Okay.
- Definitely. I had no idea.
I feel like I was like clawing
at the pop and the rock world,
and I felt so much,
now, like in reflection,
like, I feel like I
thought I had to be someone
that I thought I had to be
to get people to like me
or understand me
or validate me.
- Get you.
- And then I started being
in more of the country
environment.
- Yeah.
- And I'm from southern Ohio.
My family on my mom's
side still lives there.
And it was a part of me
that I kept really secret
and private, cause it was
just my real true family.
And when I started playing
these country shows,
I felt like I was singing to my brother
and to my, my nieces and
my nephews and my Pawpaw.
And I felt like I could just like,
release and exhale and
have fun and be myself
and through that
- It feels like home.
- Yeah. It feel,
it feels like home.
- Yeah.
- And because the country fans
are so like, loving and loyal,
if you can win them over.
- Yeah.
- I, I wanted to open up
more about myself and,
and share more about my life.
And that's what I did with the record
and I'm very proud of that.
- And now with country music,
well, and congratulations by the way,
that's an amazing thing
to like figure out,
but I feel like country too now,
is like a several different lanes.
There's like, I think
that's the thing too.
They're a little bit
more open now.
- Yeah.
- Rather than just one way of doing it.
But I am such a fan of you.
I think you're
- Thank you.
- so fantastic.
- I'm a fan of you.
- Yeah. I'm just, I love the song you do
with Miranda as well.
- Oh, thank you.
- So good.
- Yeah.
- Thank you.
- I love, I love everything you.